though he may not be at his most
recognizable in his role in guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 the actor who plays
sulk in the Marvel sequel is bound to
look familiar to any avid movie goer his
name is Tommy Flanagan an actor with a
mile-long resume and a pair of
distinctive scars he's one of those
actors whose name you can't quite
remember but whose face you know by
heart here are a few flicks you might
have seen him in Bravehearts Flanagan is
an extraordinarily Scottish man so it
should come as no surprise that his
first big break was in 1995's Braveheart
the epic historical drama directed by
and starring Mel Gibson Flanagan played
a villager named Morrison whose wedding
is interrupted by the repulsive Lord
bottoms who steals Morrison's bride for
the night happily Morrison gets his
revenge when he joins William Wallace's
army my rice you're late
I'm here to clean up the Saint this 1997
thriller cashed in on the bin solid
super star status of Val Kilmer who was
coming off as one movie standards Batman
still sporting an action hero's physique
perfect for his role in the sink
Keller plays the lead role a smarmy
thief for hire with the world's most
ridiculous collection of disguises who
earlier because want to get some coffee
or something
of course the billionaire Russian
oligarch who enlists the Saints also
needs a couple of loyal henchmen to help
with his schemes inter Flanagan who
joined the cast as a thug known as
Scarface for the most part his role
consists of hovering nearby and looking
intimidating Flanagan was apparently not
a fan of the movies leading man in 2004
he slowly and precisely said this into
one journalist tape-recorder Val
Kilmer's a prick faced off not content
to play just one role per year as the
right-hand man to a movie villain in
1997 Flanagan also showed up in John
woos brilliant and brilliantly absurd
face off a film that was a giant hit at
the box office despite its repulsive and
ridiculous premise Flanagan plays Leo a
henchman to the evil castor Troy a role
played by both Nicolas Cage and John
Travolta you know because of the stay
swapping thing I'd like to take his
his face
Flanigan turns up in multiple scenes as
a strong silent member of the villain
support staff where he's easily
identifiable as a bad guy thanks to his
stylishly sleazy turtleneck and blazer
combo the game 1997 was a big year for
Flanagan after playing a couple of
toughs in the st. and faceoff he also
had a memorable turn as a crazy cabbie
in the game a twisted David Fincher
thriller
Michael Douglas starred as a
cold-hearted businessman who ends up
fighting for his life on his 48th
birthday in an elaborate role-playing
game gone mad Flanagan is on camera in
this for only about 15 seconds and has
zero lines but his performance makes a
big impression
gladiator with one historical epic
already under his belt
Flanagan scored an even bigger part in
his next one in 2000 Ridley Scott's
gladiator
where he played Maximus his loyal
servant Cicero it was one of the actors
most significant cinematic roles yet and
it really showed off his range
not only did Flanagan demonstrate that
he makes a totally convincing good guy
complete with a noble and dramatic
on-screen death
but he also toned down his thick accent
considerably to the hostess Charlie's
Angels full throttle
Hollywood's always in need of a few good
bad guys and by 2003 Flanagan was high
on the list of the industry's most
eligible henchmen
his nameless roughhouser and Charlie's
Angels full throttle credited only as
Irish henchman was part of the squad
assembled by the evil Irishman Seamus
O'Grady Flanagan took plenty of licks
from the ladies but says Lucy Liu was
the hardest hitting angel in the trio
Sin City Flanagan next turned up in
Robert Rodriguez's gruesome 2005 film
Sin City there he played a mercenary
named Brian in a vignette titled the big
fat kill where he memorably chucks a
grenade at a mute assassin so couldn't
get stupid back and then makes an
elegant escape down a manhole with
Benicio del Toro severed head surely a
career highlight when a stranger calls
this 2006 remake of the classic horror
film features plan again as the namesake
stranger who terrorizes a hapless
babysitter with a series of threatening
phone calls
although Flanagan doesn't actually speak
in when a stranger calls the creepy
voice on the line belongs to actor Lance
Henriksen from the alien series the
image of him in the back of a police car
in the film's final moment make it clear
why he was the perfect casting choice
sons of anarchy
Flanigan's best-known role is also the
one he played the longest as fan
favorites chibs Telford on the FX series
sons of anarchy jockey boy does play
says fantastic
I'm so excited the show tells the story
of a gun-running motorcycle gang that
may or may not be loosely based on the
famous Hells Angels Flanagan played
Telford for all seven seasons as he rose
in the ranks to become sergeant-at-arms
vice-president and finally president
motorcycle guy nice guys don't always
finish last there's more still don't
know where you've seen Flanagan over the
years you may have spotted him on one of
several high-profile primetime
properties including revenge
Gotham and a memorable turn is a
loanshark on Law & Order SVU in which he
actually has the gall to threaten ice-t
until your girlfriend she's going to
sorry sledding into this check while we
just add that to the rest of your charge
going toe to toe with ice-t
that's pretty cool thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]